اغلاق مكاتب تويتر بلا سبب سياسات جديده
للمنصه وحكومات وسفارات تستعد للاسوء في
حاله تعطله مؤقتا هذا بعض من المؤشرات
والتغيرات التي قد تحدده مصير تويتر في
المرحله المقبله ايلون ماسك الذي استحود
على تويتر توجه الى منصته ليشارك العالم
سياسات جديده قائمه على حريه التعبير
وليست على حريه الوصول على حد قوله ماسك
اوضح ايضا انه سيتم الغائه نشر التغريدات
السلبيه التي تحد على الكراهيه
نهج جديد يتبعه ماسك لتحسين منصه العصفور
الازرق حيث لجا الى المغردين بتغريده تحت
عنوان ما الذي يجب ان يفعله تويتر منهم من
قال تعزيز منع الاحتلال على المنصه واخر
يرغب باضافه خاصيه تحرير التغريدات واعاده
ترتيب التعليقات بطريقه اذكى سياسيا قرر
ماسك اجراء استطلاع على تويتر يطلب من
المستخدمين التصويت على اعاده تفعيل حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
المنصه وصوت الاغلبيه على رغبتهم بذلك
تداعيات موجه الاستقالات جراء عمليات
التسريح السريع للموظفين من قبل ماسك
تسببت في ظهور هاشتاج ار اي بي تويتر على
المنصه يوم الخميس والجدير بالذكر انها
ليست الاولى مع تساؤلات لاحتماليه توقف
المنصه عن العمل او ما اذا كان الموظفون
الباقون قادرين على الحفاظ على الشركه هذا
وقد رصدت صحيفه نيو تايم غيرات المفاجئه
والسريعه لتعطي قراءها نصائح لحفظ ارشيف
تغريداتهم خصوصا مع وضع المنصه الحرج
واحتماليه عدم صموده وفق الصحيفه واشنطن
بوستنماركيه نقلا عن مصادر داخل تويتر مع
استعداد سياسيين وحكومات وسفارات للاسوء
في حال تعطل تويتر بشكل مؤقت رئيس اداره
الثقه والامن في تويتر سابقا قال في مقال
لصحيفه يور تايمز عندما يحدد مستقبل تويتر
ليس فقط الخيارات التي تتخذها الشركه ولكن
كيفيه القيام بها رشا خياطه العربيه